[Music]
the following presentation was created
by
wired we've quantified your digital
footprint so that you can see the impact
you've had on the internet oh
that's cool that's neat
[Music]
i wonder what it means
this is what happens when you google the
try guys all right
what that's too many three very common
words it does not surprise me
1 billion 540 million
wait yeah i did it yeah and it only took
0.71 seconds to find that many google
you sure are trying to
you failed looks like the first video
that pops up is the try guys try
korean snacks for the first time iconic
not exactly not especially a big hit
yeah or
that great and next the try guys try to
make pants without instructions
that's one of our favorite recent videos
yeah so with that instruction series is
about us doing things without
instructions yeah we like to try guys
without blank titles need to be very
literal for us
it writes itself there's a try guys wiki
wow we have a whole
fan wiki and it's not even just about
feet that's awesome wow that's huge for
me i had no idea that existed
i have no idea what could be in the wiki
it's probably just that we said
one section that comes up is people also
ask what happened to the try guys
it was a terrible plane crash when it
didn't happen to us like the arrow i
need to know
are the try guys really friends no we're
lovers
friends doesn't even begin to describe
what we are we're friends
with benefits i'd say we like to think
of ourselves more as brothers because
friends get into arguments and split up
brothers get into arguments and stay
together
brothers don't have a choice yeah i was
adopted
who is the most popular try guy you know
look it's hard to say who
eugene yeah quantifiably eugene
and qualitatively eugene he has a lot
more instagram followers
i like to think of myself as the most
popular
anyway that's what i like to think who
started the try guys
technically the four of us did it
together i'd say the most common
misconception is that
uh we were cast together but
we it was a self-made thing we found
each other and it was really actually
i think you could say the audience
created the try guys we made a video
it worked they asked for more here we
are that's right
who created the try guys you you did
baby
oh god this is a google trends graph of
the try guys searched over time
a b and c three points here what do we
think a is
it's probably the start of us yeah
what's the date oh you know what though
i bet you that's our motherhood series
because look you see the beginning of
the try guys oh yeah
so a is going to be our motherhood
series b is probably when we launched
our new company in our new channel yeah
and then
c has to be our summer of try
where a whole bunch of things happened
we went on a 20 city tour
eugene released a music video coming out
called i'm gay
we also uh released our book
the hidden power of effing up i mean it
was just like the
the biggest wildest summer of our lives
and a podcast and a podcast overdue for
another spike
what's going on steady decline per
google image search here are some
other words associated with the try guys
speedo
with a photo in target
oh that's definitely key that's normal i
got a freak tongue baby
aesthetic i am aesthetic thank you
testosterone
we did a very controversial testosterone
test this is very funny actually any
testosterone searches are from uh
alt-right trolls soy
i love that so it's all about william
yeah i'm telling you man there was a
huge soy boy moment where they were
trying to use us to prove some
feminization yeah garbage and i you know
from all to hell we
try to combat toxic masculinity through
our videos and our work
uh sometimes people who are toxic try
and fight back
also we don't care yeah we don't care
yeah i look i think with
everything that we do we try to show
that there is no one right way to be
a man to be a person and yeah you can
still be tiny and delicate and cute and
still be awesome
you can be big and suck
uh magic mike yes i do resemble
channing tatum from the face down
honestly if you read all of these
together it sounds like
a mad libs for bad porn
we searched reddit for the try guys and
these were some of the top results can
we guess
what they are based on the name of the
subreddit r beauty guru
chatter hmm i think this one is
we recreated uh some beauty gurus iconic
looks
so i bet that's what you said say gurus
you said guru yeah you're like a gyro
there we go beauty guru well you're
right med
all right hey yeah i'm right
we went on ebay and found the least
expensive and most expensive items when
searching the try guys
what i have no idea what they can do you
didn't even know we were on ebay there's
some knockoff
like these knockoffs or are these like
maybe someone is selling like a signed
hoodie from the tour or something
yeah they could be recently something
i'm very excited let's see what the
starting bid is
hundred dollars two hundred dollars
probably like a signed hoodie
it's a signed copy of our book oh wow
yo i'm gonna tell you what you're
getting you're overpaying for that we're
still selling them
we still have them and they don't cost
that much goes tryguys.com
50 bucks they googled keith habersberger
and these were
some results there's only 305 000. that
feels like
drastically less than the billions of
try guys but let's see what we got
that still feels like a lot of times
yeah but i'm worried that they're
starting with me because i'm the lowest
number
why did keith habersberger leave worth
it
everybody thinks they kicked me off the
show that's not true
i had something else to do i was very
supportive of them everybody's like he's
a dick i'm not a dick i was very
supportive the whole time everyone was
real mean to me about it for some reason
i never understood why
so keith you chose us over with it i did
and i i've been writing it ever since
have you seen the graph
oh here are some related image searches
of me i'm excited for that keith
eversberger funny face
which one is it it's the one that i
screenshot
yeah you know i think that might be the
screenshot i took
and i posted all over twitter and i was
like this is my new reaction
it's my favorite wow which i first i
first was using as a reaction meme on
our text threads
you infiltrated his google search wow
it's a beautiful funny it's
it it shakes me to my core spiritually
ethically it is against god's
design here are some top reddit search
results for keith habersberger sorted by
relevance dancing with the stars no
way am i going to be on dancing with the
stars are you kidding me
let me dust off some moves
[Music]
when searching amazon for keith
haversberger you found the following
product it's probably chicken sauce yeah
chicken sauce
you can buy your own bottle of quiche
chicken sauce in a three pack on
amazon.com
i have a line of hot sauces uh they're
delicious they're not too hot get
yourself some
i like the burger sauce more i'm just
gonna say it i think burger sauce is
better i like the original better
it's great on eggs it's great on sausage
great on pizza
it's great on everything but you know
i'm a big ranch boy we googled ned
fulmer and these were some results
people also asked about me what is ned
fulmer's real name
ned fulmer no no my i mean maybe they're
asking
yeah what is my real name my real name
is edward
well we found out that ned's that real
name was edward we were all shocked to
the core
shocked inside try guys ned fulmer's
custom california
home from architectural digest
my wife and i did a home renovation and
to reveal it
we were featured on architectural digest
she's very proud of it it's a huge deal
it's a big deal
i am also very proud of it surprise
pregnancy announcement to wes
ned and ariel we just had a new
baby uh and when we found out about it
we told our son wes
you know we have the try guys channel i
have a couple videos on my personal
channel it's mostly
surprise pregnancy announcements some
related image searches for me
i net former eye i don't know what this
one is
you have a very beautiful eye color oh
thank you maybe it's from that one
picture of you where your eyes are so
insane
oh yeah that must be it you know how
sometimes you smile for a photo but then
the photo turns out and it doesn't
really look
right full frontal flash me smiling like
this
we go with that cornfield and these were
some of the results 409
000 took 2.1 seconds so they really had
to work for that
google was struggling i'm sure there's
not more no there's not more
keep looking this one's from washington
post want to top the box office during a
pandemic
film for free on zoom and then rent out
a theater this is very exciting look we
all have amazing talents and skills
however i am the only official movie
star of the try guys yes i was the star
of the number one movie
in america uh my buddy eric tabac had
this idea during the pandemic
that since there were no new movies
coming out we could film a movie
rent out a theater and then just buy all
the tickets again and again and again
so he did that uh and i think with 26
000 it was the number one movie in
america that week
very exciting for me very depressing for
the state of the movie industry
i get to say forever that i was the star
of the number one movie
of america it's just one of the many
things will smith and i have in common
we search zach kornfeld on getty images
can you tell us about these
oh yeah this is me being the doggo
and or [ __ ] for poppy poppy is a friend
of ours she is a wonderful weird
musician
we were hosting the streamies and she
came with uh
three leather-bound gimps gimps
she was walking them like they were dogs
and she was backstage and she was very
sad and i said poppy what's wrong
and poppy said well the producers won't
let me bring my gimps on stage
and i said well poppy i'll do it and she
went really
i'm like yeah i'm the host what are they
gonna do it's live let's do this
they can't fire me we're in the middle
of a show so uh she put a leash on my
neck and i start walking out and i see
the producers go like
no and then they kind of were like okay
okay
yeah then the following year they
elected not to have a host our life is
very weird i'm realizing
yeah like this alone should be the
weirdest moment of my life
i kind of forgot about it i don't google
myself
very much i terrified of seeing what the
internet has to say about
me cause you know it's just not
comfortable so i
really have no idea what's gonna come up
we googled the eugene liang and these
were some
results
12.5 million that's because you put
eugene liang and i'm gay
oh perhaps maybe perhaps you don't think
it's because lee and yang are two of the
most powerful oh yeah maybe now
that's maybe that's it jean liango's
viral cosplaying avatar the last
airbender
yeah i think there was actually a lot of
press coverage i wasn't aware of of my
cosplays i did
uh zuko azula and kiyoshi
from one of my favorite american
animated series
and people loved it 15 lgbtq youtubers
brie larson should collab with yeah that
would be fantastic brie larson is
amazing and she i believe
started a youtube channel eugene liang
movies and tv shows
comfort girls uh so this was actually a
short film i produced
and it was part of a asian american
film organization that i was a part of
and it was an amazing short film we've
seen it it's fantastic it's cool he's
very talented i'm not a princess
huh so that was actually a spec music
video i made
for the artist marina and the diamonds
who's amazing self-funded it self-cast
it choreographed it created this entire
12-minute video it was me
re-interpreting old fairy tales and
turning the gender norms on their heads
here are some of the top reddit search
results for eugene liang sorted by
relevance
ah so this is my coming out video i
still watch this video all the time
eugene liang from buzzfeed slash the try
guys comes out as gay
with a beautiful choreography to one of
my favorite odessa songs posted to
r slash late bloomer lesbians
well i love that reddit uh group we were
going on a tour where my entire section
was about being gay and i was about to
bring gay pride across the nation and
not my
my whole family didn't know i was gay so
i had to make something and so i
uh basically was gonna do it on my own
and then i was like why would i do this
because we have a company so
i was like okay i'll put it on the
channel and i did it within a month
this was an interesting example and
you'll probably see more of this in our
documentary
of my public life especially as a video
producer
preceding my private life and it sort of
forced my hand
and so i had to respond to it through my
public work
and so it was very emotionally difficult
and
i would say that in the end it was a
great excuse to be able to come out to
some people i'm close to but yeah that's
fantastic i really
hope that anyone who still comes across
this video anew
is moved by it or feels something from
what i have to say in the moment and
yeah i'm still incredibly proud of
the conversation that it started i would
not advise anyone publishing
a multi-million view video to come out
to your parents
but but in the end it worked out really
well because i think the impact
also helped people i loved show how
important this is to an entire community
so yeah you know in the end it worked
out
we searched eugene liang on getty images
can you tell us about these images
oh my this photo was actually from the
first comedy show i was ever part of and
keith attended with becky yeah and um it
was basically storytelling from a lot of
queer
entertainers i actually thought it went
pretty well i
basically did like a country music redo
of my
my childhood fun fact i really love
country music
uh such tall hair this was from the
asian americans end of the year award
show
this was the first year i attended i was
honored with breakout
male star which was fantastic this was i
think 2016 but
i was also honored alongside like
stephen yoon and
i mean there were actual stars there i
was just that was just like
little old me it was crazy because the
asian american community especially
in hollywood are very tight and we're
all very supportive
and this is my favorite award show to go
to because after this i made this sort
of the
platform for me to really express a lot
of my genderqueer style
so the subsequent years i just got gayer
and gayer and gayer and man do some of
those old asian guys not know what
they're looking at
but yeah you knew i was strutting around
and that was one of the years
mulan herself ming na wen came up to me
and said i was a gorgeous unicorn
and i cried and i never cry i was also
very drunk
because they are also always sponsored
by whiskey brands because they
are run by koreans and we love whiskey i
feel like that's a pretty good bye line
for you most of the time
really gay and beautiful and also drunk
that's true
the internet can be a really divided
place it can be really brutal and scary
and volatile but we always try to put as
much good in the world as we can
i think a lot of these results prove
that a lot of good comes back to you
yeah i was surprised at how warm and
nice a lot of those responses were
maybe maybe not the soy testosterone
stuff sure but
they didn't know they don't know how
much we don't care about that uh thank
you for having us wired we are the try
guys go check out our movie and until
next time
get that graphire
that's how we gave it a try